[Musik]
[Applaus]
china hat eine entscheidung getroffen
der freiheit hongkongs ein ende zu
bereiten
[Musik]
ende mai 2020 stimmte der nationale
volkskongress das höchste gesetzgebende
organ der volksrepublik china
für die umsetzung eines neuen
sicherheitsgesetze in hongkong das den
chinesischen regime die möglichkeit gibt
all diejenigen zu verfolgen die in der
des halbautonomen statt reden halten
oder politische ideen und botschaften
propagieren ein gesetz das ist der
chinesischen diktatur auch erlauben wird
ihre sicherheits und geheimdienste nach
hongkong zu entsenden um alle abweichler
unter regime kontrolle zu bekommen in
diesem dass sie auf dem bildschirm sehen
könnt stimmt zwischen pink selbst für
dieses gesetz dieses bild zeigt wie sie
china langsam die ehemals als perle des
ostens bekannte stadt einverleibt ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen unter dem
schatten der geheimpolizei zu leben
erscheint dass die letzte feier wohl die
unsere freiheiten schützt kurz vor dem
zusammenbruch steht
ein student der universität hongkong
gegenüber der lg hannes
das modell von einem land zwei systemen
das den menschen in hongkong garantiert
wurde wird vollständig zerschlagen
dies ist die traurigste zeit in hongkong
ich habe keine worte um unser gefühl der
verzweiflung in worte zu fassen dennis
kock pro demokratisch ist mitglied des
legislativrat hongkongs hongkongs
hedgefonds erkunden den ausstieg falls
sich das gesetz zur nationalen
sicherheit abzeichnet financial times
[Musik]
dies ist ein thema das uns bei visual
politik besonders am herzen liegt und
über das wir bereits in einem video
gesprochen haben eine frage bleibt
jedoch unbeantwortet wie hat die
internationale gemeinschaft auf das was
wie der anfang vom ende einer der bisher
größten städte der welt aussieht
reagiert nun die wahrheit ist dass der
internationale verurteilung ganz
eindeutig extremst lau war so extrem
lauwarm das ist in einem innerlich kocht
und man gleichzeitig friert man kann
sagen dass im allgemeinen praktisch
nichts gesagt oder getan wurde bisher
war das land das am meisten lärm gemacht
hat die usa welche damit gedroht haben
hongkong nicht nur als autonomes gebiet
zu betrachten und das könnte bedeuten
dass einige der vorteile die diese stadt
in ihren beziehungen zu den vereinigten
staaten hat bald verschwinden
die regierung von donald trump verhängte
heute starke sanktionen gegen hongkong
außenminister propos informierte den
kongress das hongkong ab sofort nicht
mehr als autonom angesehen werde und
daher keine privilegien mehr nach
us-recht geleast wir sprechen von
privilegien wie ihr reduziertes fällen
freien personen- und kapitalverkehr fast
unbegrenzten zugang zu us technologie
und dem fehlen von beschränkungen für
den devisen
dieses drohpotenzial im kommerziellen
sektor ist jedoch kaum von bedeutung da
die direkten exporte aus hongkong in den
vereinigten staaten minimal sind
regierung trump bestraft offizielle aus
hongkong für das harte vorgehen gegen
demonstranten die regierung von
präsident dort schon verhängte am
freitag sanktionen gegen hong kongs
chief executive chairman und zehn
weitere hochrangige offizielle in
hongkong und auf dem chinesischen
festland wegen ihrer rolle bei der
bekämpfung politische abweichler
[Musik]
die vereinigten staaten sind jedoch
nicht das einzige land dass maßnahmen
ergreift in der tat wurden trotz der
lauwarme internationalen reaktion und
über die anwendung von sanktionen hinaus
die zumeist die menschen in hongkong
selbst bestrafen würden einige maßnahmen
auf den tisch gelegt die ebenso
einfallsreich wie potenziell wirksam
sind die befreundeten visual bot die
karte ist gut zu denn wir werden die
wichtige frage behandeln wie hongkong
gerettet werden kann
die hong kong
also schauen wir mal wenn es ein land
gibt das eine besondere verantwortung
für das trägt was in hongkong passieren
könnte dann ist es großbritannien
schließlich wurde fast die hälfte aller
hongkonger bürger geboren als hongkong
noch durch die britische krone regiert
wurde und genau das ist es was die
regierung des vereinigten königreichs
veranlasst hat etwas kräftiger auf den
tisch zu hauen natürlich auch eine ganz
andere weise als die vereinigten staaten
schau dir die folgende schlagzeile an
denn hier kannst du sehen das ist uns
britannien ernst meint boris johnson
verspricht drei millionen menschen aus
hongkong ins vereinigte königreich
aufzunehmen new york times
ja das stimmt die erste reaktion der
britischen behörden bestand darin eine
art rettungsleine auszuwerfen für alle
menschen in hongkong die sich durch die
wachsende einschränkungen durch die
chinesische diktatur bedroht fühlen wie
wir alle wissen gehört hongkong bis zum
ersten juli 1997 zum vereinigten
königreich dem zeitpunkt an denen die
übertragung seiner souveränität in
chinesische hände erfolgte obwohl sie
bis 1997 teile des vereinigten
königreichs waren hatten hongkongs
bürger jedoch seit den 1960 er jahre
nicht mehr die britische
staatsbürgerschaft sondern lediglich das
recht die sogenannte britische übersee
staatsangehörigkeit zu beantragen ein
status der jedem der etwa 350.000
hongkong an die dafür in frage kommen
einen britischen reisepass und die
möglichkeit gibt die dienste von
botschaften und konsulaten des
vereinigten königreichs auf der ganzen
welt in anspruch zu nehmen
es handelt sich jedoch um einen status
der aber nicht das recht gewährt im
vereinigten königreich zu leben oder zu
arbeiten was die regierung von boris
johnson jedoch deshalb vorschlägt würde
viel weiter gehen es würde einerseits
die möglichkeit bieten dass die fast
drei millionen menschen die vor 1997 in
hongkong geboren wurden sich erneut um
diesen status bewerben können und zum
anderen die rechte dieser status mit
sich bringen würde erheblich erweitern
die idee die die regierung auf den tisch
gelegt hat ist dass dieser status als
britischer übersee bürger nun allen
inhabern erlauben würde zwölf monate
lang im vereinigten königreich zu
bleiben inhaber können problemlos
beantragen indem dann zu arbeiten und
studieren zu können wo diese zwölf
monats frist könnte dann problemlos
verlängert werden und nicht nur das in
der britischen regierung positiv dass
diese methode auch eine abkürzung zur
vollen britischen staatsbürgerschaft
wäre
[Musik]
wenn china diesen weg fortsetzt und
diese nationale sicherheitsgesetzgebung
umsetzt werden wir dies tun wir werden
es den inhabern von pässen britischer
übersee bürger erlauben in das
vereinigte königreich zu kommen fühlen
sich für längere zeiträume von zwölf
monaten zum arbeiten und studieren zu
bewerben und ihnen im gegenzug den weg
zur künftigen staatbürgerschaft eröffnen
dominik raab außenminister des
vereinigten königreichs
[Musik]
das bedeutet dass das vereinigte
königreich den bürger hongkongs einen
ganz neuen fluchtwege sind aber wartet
einen augenblick date london wirklich
dass plötzlich hunderttausende von
einwohnern hongkongs ihre sieben sachen
packen und nach großbritannien ziehen
nun offensichtlich nicht wenn diese
initiative jedoch in die tat umgesetzt
würde hätten die meisten 100 bürger
einen sehr attraktiven weg um den
exzessen der chinesischen regierung
zusammengekommen das bedeutet dass jeder
der anspruch darauf hat leicht entkommen
kann wann immer er es für richtig hält
ohne das komplizierte verfahren eines
politischen asylantrags durchlaufen zu
müssen wenn beispielsweise wie es die
chinesische regierung zu wollen scheint
ihre kontrolle über hongkong und die
freiheiten der menschen in hongkong
verschärft werden soll könnten sich
viele politiker unternehmen dissidenten
und studenten die jederzeit in eine sich
am hafen mit allen garantien begeben die
sie brauchen würden und nicht nur das
gleichzeitig würde es die chinesische
regierung dazu drängen noch mal darüber
nachzudenken bevor sie die roten leine
überqueren denn dies könnte zu einer
völligen abwanderung von fachkräften und
talenten führen es ist eine situation
die eine residenz fall darstellt 900
60er und anfang der 70er jahre haben der
ugandische diktator idi amin und die
kenianische regierung zehntausende
menschen südländischer abstammung
ausgewiesen die in vielen fällen einen
britischen pass besaßen
angesichts dieser situation ermöglicht
es die britische regierung des
konservativen etwa hieß im jahre 1972
dass tausende dieser flüchtlinge sich im
vereinigten königreich niederlassen fast
30.000 menschen folgten weg und sie
wurden zu einer der sozial und
wirtschaftlich erfolgreichsten gruppen
von einwanderern des vereinigten
königreichs stehen wir also vor einer
genialen lösungen die unter den
gegebenen umständen die beste mögliche
antwort auf die bedrohung durch china
sein könnte nun im gegensatz zu
sanktionen bestraft sie nicht die
menschen in hongkong selbst sondern gibt
ihnen eigentlich eine ganz neue hoffnung
und zukunft und es ist ein schritt wäre
china sicherlich wütend gemacht
[Musik]
die regierung von sinkingen hat bereits
deutlich gemacht dass sie absolut gegen
diese maßnahme ist und hat mit
vergeltungsmaßnahmen gedroht und wenn
peking über vergeltungsmaßnahmen spricht
wir sicher sein dass es sich um
finanzielle vergeltungsmaßnahmen handelt
und die celeste ernsthafte zweifel daran
aufkommen ob london diesen schritt
letztendlich durchziehen wird vergessen
will nicht das gewicht dass china auf
die post dragset wirtschaft ausüben
könnte die frage die sich nun auf das
jedenfalls was wäre wenn die britische
regierung unterstützung der
internationalen gemeinschaft allen
menschen in hongkong dieses privileg
gewähren würde wäre das nicht eine
meisterhaft antwort auf die shootings
expansionsdrang
wäre das nicht eine möglichkeit hongkong
zu einem symbol für das engagement
großbritanniens für freie ländern im
kampf gegen die ausbreitung des
totalitarismus zu machen nun das ist
noch nicht alles
es wurde noch eine andere idee
vorgebracht eine originelle idee die
eine revolution auslösen könnte etwas
von dem ich sagen würde es
wahrscheinlich eher nicht eintreten wird
aber auf jeden fall ist es interessant
darüber zu sprechen könntest du dir
vorstellen was passieren würde wenn
großbritannien auf seinem eigenen
territorium auf die schaffung einer art
neuen hongkongs drängen würde sagen ich
bin eben nicht in meinen eigenen
fantasien abgegriffen es handelt sich um
eine idee die das adams mit ist
vorgebracht hat und die wahrheit ist
dass sie nicht so weit hergeholt ist wie
es auf den ersten blick scheinen mag
[Musik]
nach dem beispiel der square mal also
der city of london welche über
waldreiche mit reliquien die zum
beispiel steuerfreiheit vereinigten
königreichs verfügt und vor allem
johnsons vorschlag für freiheit und
könnte das vereinigte königreich einen
standort auf seinem territorium
errichten in dem jeder bürger oder jedes
unternehmen kann geklagt werden könnte
ein raum der über regelungen und ein
steuersystem verfügen würde wie es heute
in hongkong existiert mit anderen worten
wir sprechen über die schaffung einer
sonderwirtschaftszone die zum besten
verbindungspunkt zwischen asien und
europa werden könnte während den bürger
hongkongs noch mehr möglichkeiten
geboten werden und nein das ist kein so
verrückte anders denkt bitte daran dass
ein großteil des wirtschaftlichen
erfolgs großbritanniens in den letzten
jahrzehnten auf eben jene quadraten
meine in der mitte londons
die sonderregelung zurückzuführen ist
die großbritannien für die
finanzindustrie dort geschaffen hat wo
dies wäre nun etwas sehr ähnlich ist ein
potenzielles erfolgsmodell mit erprobtem
historischen vorbild darüber hinaus wäre
es auch eine möglichkeit für das
vereinigte königreich seine
wettbewerbsfähigkeit zu erhöhen
seine verbindung zum asiatischen
kontinent zu stärken und unternehmen und
talente genau dann anzuziehen wenn es
ihre meisten braucht in der zeit nach
dem brett eine große und mutiger schritt
wenn es nicht lassen wir es aber vorerst
beenden denn neben großbritannien gibt
es noch ein anderes land das ebenfalls
sehr genau verfolgt was mit der
ehemaligen teile des ostens geschieht
das jetzt gut auf der cousin ersten
grades
in taiwan verfolgt die ereignisse in
hongkong mit allerhöchste aufmerksamkeit
und man ist sich in taipeh in einer
sache vollkommen klar wenn sich die
regierung von jean ping mit den
gewaltsamen systemwechsel in hongkong
durchsetzt könnte er nächster schritt
darin bestehen den druck auf ihre insel
zu erhöhen
eine insel die zur zufluchtsstätte für
viele dissidenten und politische akteure
geworden ist welche sich weigern vor der
chinesin diktatur in die knie zu gehen
deswegen schnellen auch die anträge von
bürgern aus hongkong auf
aufenthaltsgenehmigungen in taiwan in
die höhe
zahl der hongkong die sich um eine
aufenthaltsgenehmigung bemühen erreicht
neues hoch die zahl der personen aus
hongkong die sich um einen wohnsitz in
taiwan bewerben stieg im vergangenen
jahr um 41 prozent
natürlich wird es auch ein risiko und hp
haben sie viele zweifel die sie damit
umgehen sollen einerseits bringen sie
den bürgern hongkongs die sich gegen die
diktatur auflehnen viel zu importieren
gegen aber andererseits ist ähnlich klar
ob es das klügste ist die chinesische
regierung zu stark zu verärgern
zum beispiel in eine situation zu
bringen in der sie das gesicht verlieren
würde
vorläufig den artikel 18 des gesetzes
über hongkong und macao vor dass die
taiwanesische regierung den einwohnern
von hongkong und macao deren sicherheit
und freiheit aus politischen gründen
unmittelbar bedroht sind die notwendige
hilfe zukommen lassen muss
[Musik]
in der praxis ist dieses gesetz jedoch
nicht besonders ausgereift sein
anwendungen noch um abrufen das
verfahren für asylanträge die fristen
unterfangen wäre die versorgung der
flüchtlinge verfügbaren geldmittel
unklar
bislang wurde die taiwanesische
regierung diese büchse der pandora
einfach noch nicht genau aus diesem
grund kündigte die taiwanesische
präsident in zähringen wenn die
situation wären videos besprochen haben
peking nicht gerade freundlich gesinnt
ist ende mai die bildung einer taskforce
an welche eine endgültige entscheidung
treffen und ein für alle mal die rechte
der bürger hongkongs sicherstellen soll
die in taiwan asyl beantragen auf die
eine oder andere weise
rudi ist dass die frage auf ob die
internationale gemeinschaft die
regierung sei entschlossen unterstützen
sollte und taiwan zu einem sicheren
zufluchtsort zu machen angesichts des
wachsenden expansionismus des
totalitären regimes nach hongkong es
handelt sich um eine der wichtigen
fragen welche demokratische politiker
weltweit und internationale medien genau
jetzt auf werfen sollten denn im fall
hongkongs geht es um viel mehr als eine
einzelne stadt es wird es zu einem
symbol dafür wie die dinge in den
nächsten jahren laufen können darf man
china erlauben sich mit einem
totalitären system aber weiterhin alle
welt auszubreiten wie viele vertrags und
verfassungsbrüche kann man den
herrschern in peking noch durchgehen
lassen bevor sie endgültig blut wird
dann für sie ist hongkong ein großer
test an an dem sie entscheiden werden
wie weit sie ihren expansionismus
ungestraft treiben können und wir
glauben ehrlich gesagt ist eines der
schlimmsten dinge die passieren könnte
darin besteht dass wirtschaftliche
probleme
die chinesische regierung dazu bringen
werden ihrer politischen agenda volle
bedeutung beizumessen
denn auch die kommunisten müssen ihren
untertanen populistisches futter liefern
und wenn dies nicht mehr das exorbitante
wirtschaftswachstum sein kann werden sie
den nationalismus und militarismus karte
spielen und zu einem großen teil
geschieht dies bereits
denn machterhalt ist alles aber welche
antwort sollte die internationale
gemeinschaft angesichts dessen deiner
meinung nach auf die zunehmende
einmischung chinas in die lokalen
angelegenheiten hongkongs geben würden
wirtschaftssanktionen dem chinesischen
regime nicht noch weitere munition für
ihre nationalistische agenda liefern das
chinesische volk noch weiter in die
journalismus ecke treiben
schreibt uns eure einschätzungen in die
kommentare zu diesem video
wir hoffen dass dieses video etwas
gebracht hat falls ja gibt uns bitte
auch einen daumen hoch und unterstütze
uns in den du es mit einem freundin
teils vergiss bitte auch nicht dass wir
jede woche neue videos hochladen also
verpasst keines unserer updates
abonniere unseren kanal und klicke auf
das klinge symbol um rechtzeitig
benachrichtigt zu werden
machs gut und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]